et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec le docteur gerald ciolek médecin
urgentiste bonsoir gerald ciolek merci
de nous en direct sur arte france
d'avoir pris le temps change duplex
alors que vous êtes de garde ce soir on
nous avait interrogé ici même il ya deux
semaines vous étiez assez rassurant
estimant qu'on en faisait peut-être un
peu trop parfois que vous inspirent les
derniers développements est-ce qu'on
doit être encore serein
[Applaudissements]
alors
rassurant il faut l'être parce que comme
l'a rappelé les différents élise de la
santé il n'y a pas de cas sur le
territoire deuxièmement les patients qui
sont décédés en italie étaient des
patients extrêmement fragilisée à des
patients de plus de 70 voire 80 ans
lorsque on a toujours dit côté médical
c'est ce virus il est probablement
extrêmement contagieux mais comme l'est
la grippe par exemple la grippe est
extrêmement contagieuse
après la question c'est la virulence de
ce virus est ce que ce virus attaque
affaiblie des gens qui sont en bonne
santé ou au contraire est délétère et
virulent chez des gens qui sont
fragilisés pour l'instant à dater en
tout cas sur les cas en italie cela
confirme ce sont plutôt des patients qui
sont déjà fragilisés et déjà des
patients âgés donc les choses ne
changent pas le virus
il est très contagieux il est probable
et c'est ce que rappelle l'organisation
mondiale de la santé oms va avoir
affaire à une diffusion rapide
j'emploie le mot de pandémie à une
diffusion mondiale le point le mot
pandémie fait peur mais en réalité une
pandémie chaque année en à une pandémie
ça s'appelle la grippe donc la
contagiosité elle est certaine mais pour
l'instant la virulence elle n'est pas
plus exceptionnelle que ça alors le
député on l'a entendu ça a pris une
tournure un peu politique aujourd'hui le
député maire eric ciotti qui réclame au
premier ministre un plan d'urgence
rétablissent demandant le rétablissement
des frontières mais en tout cas un
contrôle accéléré aux frontières
terrestres avec des contrôles à la clé
en tant que médecin ça vous fait sourire
ce genre de propositions non
non ça fait pas ce en fait à deux choses
il ya la partie médicale virologique
street et c'est clair qu'un virus ne va
pas s'arrêter à la frontière et puis
avec un de la partie politique au sens
politique de santé et de gestion des
foules et jeux de gestion notamment de
la panique potentiel parce qu'on voit
bien que la température est montée d'un
cran sans mauvais jeu de mots avec
l'italie notre voisin proche avec des
gens on avait eu cette remarque à propos
de la chine et des vols où on avait
beaucoup reproché qui est peut être
contrôle de température par exemple à la
descente d avion et c'est vrai qu'en
tant que citoyen on peut comprendre que
les gens auraient aimé être rassurés en
ayant même si on sait que ce n'est pas
efficace à 100 % le fait d'avoir des
contrôles de température ça permet
peut-être d'avoir quelques cas
potentiels qui seraient des pistes et on
sait que ça n'a pas une efficacité à
100% mais ça permet de montrer déjà que
la situation est prise au sérieuse que
les autorités contrôlent un certain
nombre de choses et éventuellement sur
le plan médical de repérer un certain
nombre de patientes de pouvoir les
isoler on est encore dans une phase en
france mais on peut isoler les patients
la fenêtre de tir elle va être
relativement courte parce que on voit
bien qu'en italie ils sont à plus de 200
cas plus on a des cas qui se multiplient
plus l'enjeu n'est plus finalement de
les isoler mais vraiment de les traiter
voyez bien si on a plusieurs centaines
de patients ça va être compliqué de les
isoler on n'imagine pas pour la grippe
par exemple isolé tout le monde cette
mesure contrôle des frontières voire de
fermeture des frontières je pense pas
qu'en france on puisse fermer les
frontières mais elle aura un côté
symbolique qui serait peut-être pas
inutile ce contrôle de température ne
serait ce que pour rassurer les gens
mais on est bien d'accord que sur le
plan médical c'est pas ça qui empêchera
la diffusion du virus ce virus il est
très contagieux on le voit en italie on
sait même pas quel est le patient zéro
et et les passants source ce virus il
est
il a été transporté véhicules et de
chine et on voit bien que ça paraît
extrêmement difficile de maintenir une
situation hermétique en france avec zéro
cas sur le territoire
justement pour parler de cette isolation
entre guillemets des patients et en
italie il ya onze villes qui sont en
quarantaine en france le dispositif
sanitaire des alpes-maritimes a été
renforcée les écoliers les collégiens
mais aussi les lycéens qui sont revenus
des pays comme la chine les pays touchés
la corée du nord mais même justement le
nord de l'italie ne doivent pas
réintégrer les crèches les écoles et les
lycées avant un délai de 14 jours
c'est pas un petit peu beaucoup il n'y a
pas une psychose tout de même qu'ils
s'installent où on est quand même dans
la bonne direction
alors comme on a zéro qu'un sur le
territoire on est dans une phase où si
jamais il ya un cas où quelques cas
isolés il faut à tout prix les contenir
pour éviter qu'ils ne contaminent
ailleurs dont d'où l'idée de maintenir
ces gens n'ont pas en quarantaine en
isolement à domicile on parle
d'isolement à domicile de confinement et
c'est la meilleure technique vers si
vous êtes contagieux avec la grippe ou
avec le co vide 19 ce coronavirus le
meilleur moyen de ne pas refiler à votre
voisin passé de ne pas côtoyer votre
voisin danse et de rester confinés à
domicile c'est pas la quarantaine c'est
pas la ville qui est sous quarantaine
laisser les personnes à risque qui sont
mis en isolement à domicile et qui sont
réapprovisionnés par exemple en
nourriture évidemment et puis si jamais
il ya des symptômes à ce moment là ils
peuvent être pris en charge tout de
suite pourquoi le délai de quatre à
quatorze jours un délai qui est
discutable parce que ce délai de 14
jours c'est le délai d'incubation qu'on
suppose le délai maximal le seul
problème c'est qu'il commence à y avoir
un certain nombre de papiers
scientifiques qui montrent que ce délai
d'incubation
il est plus élevé que ça il est jusqu'à
20 voire 27 jours ce qui pousserait
peut-être a changé un peu la limite et
pourquoi pas les isoler les gens un peu
plus longtemps
je disais on est dans cette phase où on
peut encore isolées les gens imaginent
on conçoit comme en italie ou dans des
pays où comme la chine par exemple où
vous avez beaucoup de cas des centaines
de cas ça pose le problème derrière de
où les isoler et on voit bien qu'on ne
peut pas on peut les isoler à la maison
on peut ne peut pas les isoler à
l'hôpital parce que les chambres
d'isolement elles sont pas avec un
nombre infini et puis moi je suis quand
même il ya quelque chose qui m'inquiète
c'est se passant de 38 ans en italie qui
est peut-être le patient c'est à dire le
premier patient pas le patient qui
aurait introduit le virus mais ce
premier patient qui a été contaminé on
sait pas bien par qui mais en tout cas
se passait il a 38 ans donc il est jeune
il n'a pas d'antécédents médicaux et ce
patient il est en réanimation est donc
là se poseraient la question si ce virus
attaque ou s'attaque à des jeunes gens
et les conduit à des situations de
détresse vitale qui les conduisent en
réanimation se posera la question dans
notre pays d'une la capacité de
réanimation de lits de réanimation et là
on est sur un autre problème on est plus
sur un poème d'isoler les gens cercil le
nombre dépasse le nombre dépasse les
capacités d'isolement c'est ce sont les
capacités hospitalières et en
particulier de lits de réanimation et
deux ventilateurs pour pouvoir apporter
de l'oxygène à ses patients qui va se
poser très rapidement
l'instant n'en est pas là on en est sûr
les premiers cas il faut à tout prix les
isoler mais rapidement si la situation
se confirme et si on a des cas en france
il va falloir penser à dimensionner les
lits de réanimation dernière question un
gerald kerzec où on est le vaccin
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de vaccin on
est sur des traitements qui sont des
traitements symptomatiques
les chercheurs sont allés très vite ils
ont isolé ils ont génotypés ils ont
génotypés le virus il ya quelques essais
cliniques un peu partout dans le monde
notamment une équipe australienne qui
développerait un vaccin alors entre la
phase 2 on trouve le vaccin et la mise
en production de ce vaccin vous pensez
bien qu'il peut se passer beaucoup de
semaine voir beaucoup de moi la deuxième
chose c'est que ce sont des virus donc
ces virus sont capable de muter
extrêmement rapidement on le connaît
très bien avec la grille pain vous avez
la grippe qui est avec un cocktail de
vaccins qu'avec des souches de grippe
est malheureusement va très souvent le
vaccin tapez parfois un peu à côté parce
que vous avez le virus qui va être
capable de muter
donc c'est peut-être un peu le problème
aux cycles qu'ovide 19 notamment les
souches en iran qui sera gay souche
beaucoup plus virulente
donc le vaccin on n'y est pas encore des
chercheurs font des essais cliniques
entre la phase de recherches et la phase
de développement et de fabrication
il va s'écouler incertain
et puis encore une fois que les réserves
que ce virus ne mute pas plus vite que
ne troublez chercheurs une solution de
vaccination merci beaucoup général de
québec d'avoir été avec nous on vous
libère vous pouvez retourner à votre
gars merci d'avoir pris ces quelques
minutes pour le temps du direct merci à
vous reste